m
bonjour la voie est libre en direct tous
les samedis sur france 3 et nous allons
nous intéresser ce matin à toutes ces
voix qui de manière différente s'en
prennent à la garde des sceaux
christiane taubira policiers avocats et
lue ou encore gardiens de prisons sur
notre plateau pour en débattre la député
socialiste de saône-et-loire cécile
untermaier bonjour longeant le
conseiller communautaire du grand dijon
udi jean philippe morel
bonjour bonjour je précise que vous êtes
aussi avocat tout est fait dans le civil
et le secrétaire du syndicat alliance
syndicats de policiers pour la bourgogne
et la franche-comté frédéric paillard
bonjour bonjour à vous et chez vous vous
pouvez réagir comme d'habitude sur notre
site internet dans l'article consacré à
l'émission avant de rentrer dans le
détail des dossiers de la police de la
justice notre émission est en plein dans
l'actualité avec en cette fin de semaine
un nouveau 4 propos injurieux envers la
garde des sceaux des propos qui ont été
tenus par une adjointe au maire de la
commune de talent en côte-d'or tout près
d'ici et là démissionné dans la foulée
s'est excusé le procureur de la
république d'ailleurs a annoncé
l'ouverture d'une enquête
sans rentrer dans le détail l'adjointe
en question demandait à la garde des
sceaux de retourner dans sa brousse je
cite et déjà eu beaucoup de cas
similaires avec depuis longtemps un tir
de barrage dans une partie de la presse
mon impression ne s'est jamais arrivé
dans la république une attitude pareille
cécile untermaier est-ce qu'on doit se
dire que pour une partie du pays une
femme noire de gauche ne peut pas être
ministre de la justice
écoutez en tout cas aller les les propos
qui sont tenus et que vous rapportez et
que on découvre aussi dans d'autres dans
d'autres situations sont arrivés
beaucoup et qui sont déjà arrivé que
l'on peut lire dans des revues à à large
diffusion bien de traduisent
effectivement un espèce de de flottement
au niveau des valeurs républicaines on
peut quand même s'étonner mais c'est le
problème délitement de la confiance dans
les politiques alors christiane taubira
effectivement subi une violence tout à
fait singulière
qu'on a jamais on n'a jamais rencontré à
répétition avec un acharnement un effet
de meute en quelque sorte sur sur 7 sur
notre sur notre garde des sceaux il faut
s'inquiéter
au delà des propos du terreau qu'est ce
que révèle comment etc comment est ce
possible
il faut travailler bien sûr sur ses
valeurs de citoyenneté et de et de
pédagogie et dénoncer très fermement des
propos de cette nature qui détruisent un
peu un peu de démocratie et de la
république en forêt vous l'avais dit à
une réaction politique unanime
le maire a viré son adjointe on va dire
peut-être mais en même temps cette
présence et des gens qui sont des élus
qui qui ont ce type d'attitude sur les
valeurs de la république on sera
toujours réunies on est et on est bien
évidemment d'accord que les propos
racistes ou antisémites 5 qui peuvent
aussi se répandre dans la société
française d'aujourd'hui sont totalement
inacceptables et vous l'avez dit la
réaction politique était immédiate
le maire de talant a immédiatement
sanctionné par un retrait de délégations
son adjointe
effectivement il faut aller au delà il
ya peut-être un problème cité française
d'aujourd'hui
il faut remettre les valeurs de
république ou au milieu du village
parce que de tels propos qui se
répandent fictivement à longueur de
journée sur les réseaux sociaux
d'aujourd'hui la une et lui ce qui
évidemment grave mais aussi parfois les
plus jeunes on a besoin de pédagogie
républicaine je pense que c'est très
important et hesdin on va dire de
réflexion aussi pour les élus parce que
quand un élu tient en deux pros qu il
tire contre la république
il fait pas du bien la république mais
en son temps le savez notre garde des
sceaux bourguignonne rachida dati n'a
pas été non plus épargné par des
attaques et surmontent plus loin dans
l'histoire certains politiques ont été
attaqués je prends ça un mendès france à
léon blum qui ont été attaqués aussi
profondément donc malheureusement la
république est toujours et toujours à
défendre les valeurs sont à sont
systématiquement à rappeler aux plus
jeunes et la société d'aujourd'hui
fabrique paillard on disait avant
l'émission vous n'êtes pas comptable ou
fait des élus mais en même temps cette
idée de respect des institutions d
des élus de la république et plus loin
que ça des institutions vous syndicats
de police est quelque chose que vous
ressentez aussi c'est quelque chose
qu'ils ressentaient qui ressentie par
nos collègues sur le terrain dont la
mission est de plus en plus compliqué
puisque ses formes de on va dire
d'incivilités et d'irrespect sont
présentes au quotidien on va dire que
c'était le quotidien des fonctionnaires
de police voilà quelques années donc que
ça s'ouvre au grand public et qu'on
retrouve cette cette chose là sur la
place publique et sur les réseaux
sociaux n'a rien d'étonnant et pourtant
frédéric paillard c'est l'argument que
vous avez utilisé et en manifestant sous
les fenêtres de la garde des sceaux en
cochant le laxisme de la garde des
sceaux
on a eu cette grande manifestation de
policiers indiens c'est notre chapitre
suivant
c'est une première en france une
manifestation de cette ampleur la
nationale mais sous la fenêtre de la
garde des sceaux pour lui dire en gros
vous êtes trop laxistes la portée
symbolique puisque si vous voulez la la
goutte d'eau qui a quand même fait
déborder le vase la semaine dernière
c'est quand même le l'incident
dramatique qui est arrivé à notre
collègue yann qui est toujours dans un
état critique suite à une décision de
justice que l'ensemble de la profession
policière n'a pas pu interpréter elle
n'a pas réussi à comprendre quand on a
quand même dans la rue et la portée
symbolique vers les palais de justice et
les tribunaux étaient vraiment quelque
chose de symbolique s'était pas
spécifiquement contre la personne mais
c'était contre le système qu'on que
cette manifestation était tournée pour
démontrer que la compréhension de
certaines décisions est parfois
difficile alors sur les chiffres qui
sont un petit peu têtu on s'aperçoit
vous allez me dire si je me trouve qu'
il n'y a pas plus d'évasion aujourd'hui
dans des cas de permission de sortie
sous christiane taubira que sous le
mandat de rachida dati et que c'est une
loi qui avait été décidée écrite par
dominique perben
les chiffres sont un peu sont les mêmes
qui a même moins il semblerait qu'elle
ait moins d'évasion en
dans ces cas là aujourd'hui que lorsque
rachida des titres et garde des sceaux
alors pourquoi est ce que on ne l'accusé
pas du même laxisme c'est si long terme
et écoutez je ne sais pas sur l'étude
comparée entre rachida dati et
christiane taubira j'ai pas tellement
d'arguments je veux dire moi je n'ai
volontairement oui une autre femme garde
des sceaux qui qui a fait beaucoup de
mal
on y reviendra j'espère dans la décennie
écoulée un au travers quand même de la
suppression à la serpe de tous les
tribunaux d'instance et puis on a
beaucoup souffert aussi de 55 loi
relative à la halle à la peine
concernant le droit de la peine pendant
les dix ans écoulés avant le quinquennat
de françois hollande
donc on est dans une situation
extrêmement en est qui en a hérité d'une
situation extrêmement difficile
y a pas derrière ça le d'être la gauche
forcément laxiste mais je pense que
maintenant il faut il faut travailler
avec discernement et je crois que plutôt
que de libérer la parole comme on a pu
voir la parole libérée sous le
quinquennat de sarkozy par le président
de la république lui-même
eh bien il faut travailler dans le
discernement et c'est comme ça qu'on
luttera contre le front national en
disant les choses telles qu'elles sont
elle ne disons pas que la gauche est
laxiste puisqu'au contraire on a un
dispositif de sécurité et qu'on essaye
après avoir vécu la suppression par au
rabotage de 13 mille postes dans les
services de police et de gendarmerie
pendant les dix ans écoulés pendant les
dix ans écoulés
si on avait ces treize mille postes là
actuellement on oran serait beaucoup
plus à l'aise alors on essaye de
remonter la pente et en amis ont créé
5000 postes sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande parce qu'on est dans
cette obligation de le faire
on sait que vous êtes sous pression
vraiment on sait que vous êtes sous
pression parce que la situation est
extrêmement complexe et on est avec un
outil qui a été quand même extrêmement
abîmées sous la décennie écoulée tant de
côté magistrats que côté police
gendarmerie que services pénitentiaires
on pourra y arriver on va y venir bien
sûr jean philippe morel cette opposition
police justice est à peu près aussi
vieille vous vous êtes avocat donc
j'allais dire vous êtes un peu au milieu
de ce tir là elle est à peu près aussi
vieille que l'histoire de la justice et
de la police
c'est la même chaîne pénale un peu lisse
justice avocats ce sont ceux ci deux
institutions que sont les piliers de la
république et quand la police tous la
justice ne va pas bien et on peut
comprendre et je partage la vive émotion
effectivement des fonctions police 8
est ce cette vie du ans qui était
effectivement en permission fichés s
comme étant radicaliser en prison et qui
s'est effectivement qui a commis un
cambriolage et ensuite à tirer sur les
forces de police
on a besoin d'avoir une politique pénale
cohérente et aujourd'hui les signaux qui
sont adressés effectivement vont pas
forcément dans le bon sens que ce soit
la suppression des peines plancher pour
les récidivistes que ce soit la mise en
place d'une peine un petit peu hybride
qui est la contrainte pénal le fait que
le juge d'application des peines semble
pour la population défaire ce que la
justice
en tout cas dans les juridictions les
tribunaux correctionnels et autres ont
pu décider n'est pas aujourd'hui
comprise par la population et je pense
que ces signaux sont effectivement
adressé par les politiques pénales
aujourd'hui de madame taubira
non on va dire qu'on avait essayé
d'avoir des magistrats avec nous donc
c'est pour cause de vacances scolaires
permanence des magistrats ça a été
extrêmement compliqué je le dis parce
qu'on pourrait s'attendre à une réponse
par exemple les magistrats grippe à hier
je vous ai vu le ticket quand je disais
c'est aussi vieux que la justice et la
police là c'était là la violence du fait
divers qui vous a fait réagir
est-ce que vous avez regretté d'être
peut-être récupérer politiquement dans
les jours qui ont suivi d'entendre un
certain nombre d'élus dire ben en fait
c'est tout le temps comme ça on met trop
de gens en liberté est-ce que ça a pas
dépasser un peu ce que vous vouliez
faire mais ça c'est un peu le danger de
l'exercice donc c'est vrai qu'aux
sociétés un peu préparé dans le sens où
il est vrai que la récupération
politique est toujours quelque chose sur
ce genre de mouvement social qui est
assez qui est pratiquement une pratique
on va dire institutionnels également
puisque c'est c'est l'habitude nous
n'ouvrons n'ouvre la porte à quelque
chose il faut en assumer les
conséquences mais tous tout ce qui a
découlé de toutes façons de 2,7 de cette
manifestation et ce qui s'est passé
avant et quand même la résultante de
d'un manque de moyens pour la police
d'une réforme pénale qui ont alourdi le
travail de nos officiers de police
judiciaire et de certaines choses qui
sont incompréhensibles par nos collègues
quand on parle d' incompréhension et
qu'on parle de mal être des
fonctionnaires de police
on est vraiment dans quelque chose qui
est palpable dans les commissariats
manquer ce qu'un policier par exemple ne
comprends pas aujourd'hui les policiers
qui étaient dans la rue le policier qui
était dans la rue la semaine dernière ne
comprends pas comment on peut avoir des
criminels multirécidivistes qui se
retrouvent en liberté et qu'ils peuvent
commettre des forfaits avec les
conséquences qu'on a pu avoir pour notre
collègue ne comprennent pas également
certaines lourdeurs de procédure et ne
comprennent pas également pourquoi on
leur demande toujours plus sans leur
donner les moyens d'être capable de le
faire juste pour juste pour rappel nos
collections du corps d'encadrement et
d'application sont donc gradés et
gardiens son officier de police
judiciaire pour la plupart depuis 2001
la prime afférente cette qualification
est au regard de ce que les collègues
ont comme responsabilité n'est que de 50
euros par mois donc quelque part la
revalorisation indiciaire de ce genre de
primes est rétribué des gens pour le
travail qui est fait qu'ils aient fait
normalement très convenablement haut
niveau au niveau du judiciaire je pense
que les militaires de la gendarmerie
les fonctionnaires de police du corps
d'encadrement des applications ne
démérite pas en termes judiciaires on a
des collègues qui font du beau papier
comme on dit dans les tribunaux donc
c'est celle de la grippe a légalement ça
devrait normalement être rétribué à sa
juste valeur les moyens c'est bien sur
ce que vous avez demandé vous avez
rencontré françois hollande d'ailleurs
est-ce qu'on doit élargir le sujet parce
que les moyens on en a beaucoup parlé
les moyens des forces de l'ordre
après les événements de janvier dernier
après les après les attentats on sait
que la france est toujours sous une
surveillance très forte
moi j'ai envie de poser la question aux
élus aussi vous ne répondrez après est
ce que la france a les moyens de sa
sécurité de ce qu'elle veut faire
en tout cas il faut qu'elle se la donne
et c'est ce qu'on a fait en considérant
ee en priorisant bien évidemment les
budgets poli justice avocats vous savez
on peut pas non plus tirer des chèques
bancaires sur nos enfants en permanence
mais je veux dire de gros efforts sont
faits je pense que les forces de l'ordre
l'admettent les services de police comme
de gendarmerie admettent les efforts qui
sont faits depuis 2012 mais la montée en
puissance eh bien elle prend un peu de
temps
est ce qu'on doit dire quand même il
faut le redire c'est qu'on part d'une
situation qui était extrêmement
difficile où on a supprimé par un
rabotage ce qu'on appelle la rgpp des
postes sans discernement donc on
priorise la politique de sécurité
c'est la priorité avec des objectifs qui
sont quand même important ce sont des
crédits qui ce sont des budgets qui sont
en hausse régulière ils le sont
également en 2006 on a des crédits
j'étais avec bernard cazeneuve la
semaine dernière pour discuter de la
mission budgétaire et c'est bien évident
que sa priorité c'est de doter les
services de police et de gendarmerie en
moyens et en véhicules
on sait tous en 2012 l'état du parc de
la gendarmerie comme des services de
police et là on a inscrit au budget
qu'ils ition de 2000 véhicules par an
par force de par forces de l'ordre ainsi
que 40 millions par an par force de
l'ofppt pour les moyens matériels ne
serait ce qu en armes et en gilets
pare-balles faut savoir que on a
constaté que ces forces de police et de
gendarmerie n'avaient pas toujours les
gilets pare-balles utile dans dans les
dents l'hymne dans l'est dans les
dans leur mission donc la réponse de
françois hollande que vous avez
rencontrées vous a satisfait ces
satisfaisante sur sur la forme après sur
le fond on est parti quand même sur
quelque chose qui va être un plan purée
annuel qui nous sera proposé à partir de
mars donc on attend de voir ce qui va en
sortir et surtout si les moyens vont
réellement être mis pour avoir quelque
chose qui soit vraiment ambitieux si je
fais si je peux me permettre un
parallèle le besoin de sécurité au
quotidien dans la vie quotidienne de
tout le monde est grandissant on
s'aperçoit que les véhicules l'exemple
le plus probant qu'on a c'est les
véhicules les véhicules sont devenus de
plus en plus sécurisés de plus en plus
sécurisant part des choses qui sont
coûteuses à la base mais qui une fois
qu'elles sont déployés s'avère
économiquement rentable je pense que sur
la sécurité on pourrait peut-être
essayer d'avoir cette même logique
pertinente parfaitement être vous
évoquiez tout à l'heure les réformes qui
ont été faites par les gouvernements
successifs de gauche particulier la
suppression des peines planchers la
contrainte pénale de votre point de vue
c'est une erreur ou pas on voulait viser
le coeur en partie parce que c'était un
certain nombre d'arguments du candidat
hollande et c'est le coeur du parti de
la réforme on vit les temps dangereux
on le sait depuis janvier on a fort
besoin de sécurité je crois que c'est
une revendication légitime de la société
française d'aujourd'hui et je crois
aujourd'hui que la ligne politique de
madame taubira posant soit finalement
quelques problèmes au président de la
république parce que celle ci est en
contradiction avec celle qui est
défendue par le le premier ministre
manuel valls et on voyait encore plus de
fermeté du côté scolaire mené et un
certain laxisme quand même assumé de
l'autre côté où la sanction est
finalement quelque chose qu'il faut
quand même le maximum évacuer 60 ans et
salem chiffre tout à l'heure quand on
parle de la des peines planchers il
semble manifestement que l'effet de la
réforme des peines planchers n'a rien
modifié à la récidive mais c'est un
mauvais message qui était adressé
parce que
et ses pairs des arguments forts de
nicolas sarkozy les peines plancher on
s'en souvient oui mais ça veut dire si
on supprime les peines planchers pour
expliquer aux téléspectateurs c'est que
récidiviste aura une peine minimale
alors ça veut dire qu en les supprimant
on traite de la même manière le primo
délinquants celui qui commet une
infraction pour la première fois et
celui qui en récidive et c'est un
mauvais message qui est adressé
effectivement à la délinquance un autre
souci c'est que madame taubira a annoncé
dès 2012 la fin de construction de
places en prison et les chiffres sont ce
qu'ils sont mais on avait 68 mille
détenus précisément il y a un an et en à
65000 aujourd'hui il ya 5 % de détenus
en moins et c'est aussi là un mauvais
message adressé à la délinquance alors
qu'on sait qu'il faut saturer d'ailleurs
d'une certaine dignité en prison parce
que jordi les conditions de détention
ici les personnels pénitentiaires et
dans la rue c'est aussi parce qu'ils ont
des conditions de travail très complexe
en raison d'une simple opinion sur des
mouvements en raison d'une surpopulation
carcérale
ils sont dans des difficultés
professionnelles très importante donc il
faut construire des places en prison
d'ittre ne serait ce que pour la dignité
des détenus mais aussi parce qu'il ya un
fort besoin et on gère aujourd'hui la
pénurie parce que budgétairement on a
décidé de faire des choix politiques qui
ne sont pas judicieux au regard du
besoin de sécurité d'aujourd'hui mauvais
message aux conventions de genève et je
suis absolument pas d'accord avec ce que
vous avez pas exprimé d'une part les
places en prison on a soixante sept
mille détenus une 68000 et on a
cinquante cinq mille ou cinquante six
mille places possibles en prison donc on
a une surpopulation carcérale sur
laquelle il faut bien qu'on agisse aussi
donc il s'agit pas bien évidemment de
dire ensuite que l'on sort les criminels
pour faire de la place dans les prisons
c'est qu'on imagine un autre dispositif
vous avez pendant dix ans et
particulièrement dans les cinq dernières
années
lancer un dispositif de lutte une loi de
lutte parmi les 54 que vous avez faite
sur le coup de l'émotion
en réponse à des faits divers
bouleversant le travail des magistrats
qui pour beaucoup rentrent étaient très
déstabilisés parce que chaque fois la
loi pénale changé eh bien vous avez mis
en place un dispositif la loi de 2007
puis la loi de 2009 sur la lutte contre
la récidive la lutte contre la récidive
le bilan il est négatif en fait la
récidive n'a pas
du tout diminués et c'est pour ça que la
surpopulation carcérale est celle que
nous rencontrons donc nous avons repris
les choses en main fait une large
conférence de consensus c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas considéré de facto parce
qu'on était au pouvoir qu'il fallait
changer les choses
on a au contraire rassembler les acteurs
de la justice et dans cette conférence
de consensus
il a été tout à fait admis constater
l'échec de la politique de lutte contre
la récidive et la nécessité de la
remplacer par une politique de
prévention de la récidive
donc nous sommes dans un dispositif de
il ne s'agit pas pour autant de laxisme
bien évidemment il y aura la peine
d'emprisonnement il y aura là courtes
peines d'emprisonnement et y aura
également ce qu'on appelle la contrainte
pénale qui est en quelque sorte ce qui
existe depuis 1970 c'est à dire le
sursis de mise à l'épreuve
mais un sursis une mise à l'épreuve
beaucoup plus encadré est beaucoup plus
sérieux et qui va concerner il faut
quand même calmer les choses
elle le dira à nos anneaux à nos
auditeurs c'est que ça ne va pas
concerner le criminel et ça va concerner
par exemple la personne qui est sous
addictologie d'alcool par exemple alors
est ce qu'il est nécessaire de la place
est en prison et bien ou de lui faire
une courte peine de prison non il faut
la mettre me semble-t-il dans un
dispositif très encadré 2 contre pénal
où elle a des obligations
elle a des obligations est là elle est
sous surveillance et les housses comme
comme on le dit sumann justice et on
travaille à sa réinsertion
elle n'appelle n'est pas criminel elle a
un comportement sociétal qui pose
problème et la prison n'est pas la
solution
donc on ne dit pas qu'il faut pas
d'emprisonnement ont construit au
contraire des places en prison ce que
vous n'avez pas fait en deux en soule ce
dernier quinquennat
aucun crédit n'a été mise en place pour
la construction de places de prison
en revanche nous nous les mettons en
place et nous les construisons nord
alors ne disons pas qu'on construit pas
l'anras de prison on conseille on n'est
pas contre l'emprisonnement simplement
entre l'amp
c'est pas un avocat j'ai pas en quoi
c'est le seul jeu a expliqué un avocat
qu'il n'ya pas comme réponse à
à la délinquance que l'emprisonnement il
y à l'emprisonnement bien sûr mais il ya
aussi d'autres dispositifs et nous
devons travailler là dessus et la
contrainte pénal c'est simplement tirer
les conclusions d'un échec qui était
celui de la lutte contre la récidive et
parce que je suis j'ai été magistrat
je peux vous dire que c'est jamais la
sanction qui va motiver la personne a
évité à éviter un délit alors c'est ça
qui est très incertain on superpose un
dialogue
magistrats avocats un violon gauche
droite c'est assez rare sont ceux
d'agents de dire un mot le volonté de
sanction est évidemment bien bien plus
diversifié que la seule prison et que
quand on est obligé de deux sanctionnés
par une peine de prison c'est qu'on a
échoué
par ailleurs la prévention et les autres
peines alternatives à la prison qu'il
faut évidemment privilégié parce que ce
qui compte aussi c'est aussi la
réinsertion derrière des gens qui ont
commis un acte délictueux je ne suis pas
d'accord sur les chiffres
un objectif c'était 80000 places en 2017
aujourd'hui effectivement on a cinquante
six mille places pour 65 mille détenus
ce qui est de toute façon et la france
est condamnée pour ça des conditions de
détention qui sont indignes aujourd'hui
et le gouvernement dit de gauche
d'aujourd'hui devrait quand même se
soucier
et aujourd'hui les chiffres démontrent
que la population prison a b c est ce
qui ne répond pas effectivement aux
attentes de la population
moi j'ai envie j'ai envie d'étendre la
discussion de l'élargir on a
l'impression qu'il ya une différence
entre le fond du sujet vous expliquer
tous les deux avec vous avez des avis
différents là dessus mais on est parti
finalement du message de ce que les
français entendait comme si la seule
chose qu'on pouvait utiliser ses il faut
être sévère il faut refuser la sortie
faut refuser les permissions anticipées
comme s'il y avait un décalage
finalement entre ce message et la
réalité du dossier il ya de ça un petit
peu on est dans une société qui ne veut
entendre que parler de sévérité
d'applications fm alors que la réalité
est différente parce que les politiques
ne parle que comme ça de la justice et
de la police
parce qu'il faut quand même savoir que
vous avez bien sûr des personnes détenus
emprisonnés
elles sont de l'ordre de 55 mille ou
cent trente sept mille mais vous avez
également des personnes le triple des
peines se fait en milieu ouvert faut
savoir que c'est pas une découverte la
contrainte pénale le triple des peines
est exécuté en milieu ouvert sous
contrôle sous contrôle sous main de
justice
sous contrôle du spip avec bien sûr la
coopération précieuse lourde pour elle
j'en conviens des services de police et
gendarmes
on va y venir justement juste un mot
vous avocats aussi vous la sentez cette
différence entre message supérieur de la
sanction et et la réalité de la vie du
monde
bien sûr ce que les gens saisissent pas
c'est que beaucoup de peine sont pas
exécutés ou mises à exécution trop
tardivement et ça n'a pas de sens quand
quelqu'un est condamné une sanction
quelle qu'elle soit ce qu'elle peut être
un tiges d'un travail d'intérêt général
ou autre chose et que la mise à
exécution de cette sanction mais des
mois voire des années
ça n'a plus de sens et là je suis
d'accord la sanction doit être mise en
oeuvre le plus vite possible ce qui le
décalage aussi s'explique par le rôle
des juges d'application des peines qui
parfois trans fait transforme des peines
de prison en peine alternative à la
prison
et ça la population ne le comprend pas
en moins le citoyen et le policier ne le
comprends pas mais pour le dire un mot
sur les permissions de sortie puisque on
était là dessus bien évidemment il faut
pas réagir sur le coup de l'émotion et
supprimer les permissions de sorties
elles sont nécessaires notamment dans
des cas de dignité humaine quand un
détenu perd un proche parent il est
quand même naturel qu'ils puissent et
les syndicats de magistrats ont tous
publié des communiqués pour dire c'est
nécessaire pour la réinsertion cynisme
mais après la prison est bien d'accord
la réinsertion doit être l'objectif on
est juste je m'adresse à la police parce
que sur ce sujet des permis sont sortis
vous été en première ligne
je pense que sur ce sujet là c'est
évident que le système avec le tout
prison n'est pas un système qui est qui
et qui est correct pour la société et
pour le monde dans lequel on vit
actuellement simplement après il ya des
adaptations il ya des choses sur
lesquelles nous ce qu'on demande c'est
très sérieusement que les gens qui
prennent la décision de remettre
quelqu'un dehors ou qui prennent la
décision de lui donner une chance de se
réinsérer et bien toutes les données qui
permettent de garantir cette s'être
mises en situation dans les meilleures
conditions
quand on sait quand on sait que certains
individus quand on sait que certains
individus sont dehors
en étant
son sont dehors en ayant des fiches ce
qu'on appelle des fiches s où on a des
individus qui sont susceptibles d'être
radicaliser et ça dans les services de
police s'est pas trahir un secret que de
dire que c'est fréquent on a quand même
un problème quelque part alors c'est
quoi c'est aussi le manque de moyens
pour la justice
ça veut dire que le magistrat qui va
prendre sa décision lui aussi il subit
le manque de moyens le nombre d'affaires
a dans lequel il doit prendre une
décision
je pense que la chaîne complète de
toutes façons la chaîne complète qui va
de l'interpellation sur le terrain à
l'aboutissement de la sanction et à la
prison manque de moyens
ça je pense que ces caresses et
caractérisés et à tous les niveaux où
l'on rencontre se rencontrent ces
problèmes là si vous voulez nos
collègues nous quand on demande le
recentrage de nos collègues sur le coeur
de métier de la police et c'est ce que
le président de la république annoncé
jeudi ça c'est quelque chose qui nous va
bien puisque un détenu qui est dans
l'univers carcéral et sous l'oeil la
gouvernance est sous la protection du
ministère de la justice mme à partir du
moment où il est hospitalisé dans un
établissement hospitalier dit public
il tombe sous le coup de la sécurité
publique assez nos collègues policiers
ou gendarmes qu'ils sont amenés à le
garder donc effectivement sur ce sujet
là nos collègues qui sont de garde à
l'hôpital pour qui sont de garde dans
des centres hospitaliers quelconque ne
comprennent pas l'utilité de leur
mission puisque on a quand même un
mélange des genres donc ce qu'on
voudrait c'est que ça soit clarifiée on
avait des hôpitaux carcéraux qu'avait
été fait théoriquement on devrait avoir
des places dans ces établissements là il
faudrait que la justice accepte le
principe de garder ces détenus et que
nous nous soient effectivement là en
support en cas de besoin mais il faut
pas que ça soit la mission principale du
policier alors à cropper
il nous reste une minute trente avant
avant midi on va bien sûr parler de tout
ce qui se passe autour des avocats
puisqu'il ya un mouvement de grève des
avocats qui se continue et des sceaux
nous en parler on va parler de ça juste
après les informations nous dit juste un
mot il nous reste une minute
dites-nous si les éléments de janvier
dans la vie quotidienne des policiers ça
eu un poids très fort oui les événements
de janvier c'est un poids très fort
puisqu'on entre 40 et 50 mille
fonctionnaires jours donc en termes
d'effectifs qui travaille sur la mission
vigipirate la mission
c'est quelque chose qui est très usant
pour les effectifs puisque la moindre
manifestation de voie publique
maintenant on a des difficultés pour
avoir des forces mobiles puisqu'elles
sont concentrés sur des points
spécifiques de protection qui sont on ne
peut plus logique
simplement c'est pareil aussi si on va
sur l'effet charlie l'effet charlie
s'est estompée on a eu un amour de la
police pendant deux mois et quelque part
maintenant les collègues on est reparti
on est reparti dans un principe ou les
collègues nous disent c'est bel et bien
fini
on est toujours on a toujours des
problèmes et on est toujours en butte à
une partie de la société qui n'accepte
pas certains principes élémentaires de
vie en collectivité
merci frédéric paillard pour ressources
témoignages merci à tous les trois
d'avoir des battues déjà pendant cette
première demi heure on va bien sûr donc
poursuivre après les infos ni dit en
parlant de cette grève des avocats de la
réforme de l'aide juridictionnelle
mouvement qui n'est pas terminé mais
vous allez nous le dira juste après les
informations de midi qu'on va retrouver
avec elle a besoin vous restez avec nous
et on continue ce débat dans une poignée
de minutes à tout à leur merci